all right the big news in the NFL
continues to be the Robert Kraft
solicitation of prostitution case
yesterday out of the blue on a Monday
morning the NFL issued a new statement
as relates to the charges against Kraft
reminding everyone that the personal
conduct policy is indeed in play and we
already knew that but the NFL felt
compelled for whatever reason to let us
know that our personal conduct policy
applies equally to everyone in the NFL
we will handle this allegation in the
same way we would handle any issue under
the policy we are seeking a full
understanding of the facts while
ensuring that we do not interfere with
an ongoing law enforcement investigation
we will take appropriate action as
warranted by the facts so I thought
immediately why are they doing this and
I think that the reason was they want
everyone to know that they're not going
to issue any judgement any ruling any
punishment until the criminal case ends
whenever that may be and who knows when
it may end all we've seen from Kraft so
far is that he categorically denies the
allegations that came through a
spokesperson on Friday he's hired a
lawyer in Florida there's no reason to
believe at this point he's not going to
fight this tooth and nail as long as it
takes to exonerate himself and if that's
the case if this plays out over weeks
months years who knows how long it will
take the NFL is not going to do anything
until it's over and that that I think
was the purpose of yesterday's statement
also I think they wanted to get out
ahead of the affidavit that came out
yesterday that had some specific details
that we're not gonna go into you can
find them online if you want to see them
but the details of what ultimately
resulted in the two counts of
solicitation of prostitution that came
out yesterday at a press conference and
also the documents available
so maybe the NFL felt compelled to get
that out there to avoid what quite
possibly could have been big cat a a
push by people in the media to say you
have to do something right now NFL the
NFL is making sure everybody understands
no that's not how we do it we wait until
the criminal case ends so the
interesting story to me here now becomes
what the NFL will do in terms of
suspension for Robert Kraft and what
they will do in terms of a fine that's
maybe lesser the case because at the end
of the day I don't really care what
happens
Rober crafts money just like I didn't
really care what happened in Jimmer so
his money but Jim Irsay gets suspended
six games for his DUI arrest and it's
fine because no one even like notices
that he's not there this is different
because the Patriots have won the
Superbowl they will have the the banner
raising people will watch it it will
probably be the Sunday Night Football
game it's actually lucky that the NFL
had already floated there's a
possibility it's gonna be bears Packers
to start the season so they don't have
this be the conversation in Game one but
the question to me to you Mike as a
former lawyer is do you think Robert
Kraft is going to sit here and say let's
get this figured out right now so it
doesn't just keep hanging over
everything or will he try to draw it out
so that he can make sure that he's part
of that ceremony when they do raise
their six banner in the first week of
September yeah I mean all we know right
now is he's categorically denied the
allegation and if he does decide he's
gonna fight this then he's gonna be
around until it's resolved and if they
say hey let's delay this lets you know
and you get a skilled defense lawyer
that that lawyer will know all the
tricks all the things and I don't mean
trick in a negative way that they'll
know how to advance the interest of
their client they'll know how to to
fulfill the direction they've been given
and if the direction is make this take
as long as it possibly can they'll know
how to do that and and if and if Kraft
wants to fight this and if and if the
determination is you know what I'm gonna
stand up in the face of this thing and
I'm gonna fight it and let's make it
take as long as it takes I have a right
to a speedy trial I don't want one let's
take our time with this let's get
continuances let's build delay into this
because I want to be around for the 2019
season that's his prerogative now but
there's one thing here and we talked
about this on the radio side as it
relates to trying to get an idea of what
the NFL wants from him you know if the
NFL wants him to wrap it up quickly and
and there's kind of a wink and a nod
from the league office that if you do
wrap this up quickly if you plead a
lesser included offense or one of the
two counts and and you know whatever it
is something less than pleading guilty
to everything but you wrap it up you
plead to something and it all goes away
from a criminal justice standpoint then
here's what your punishment will be
if he's expected to do that or if
there's any effort to get him to do that
think back to 2015 with deflategate
because when he decided not to push the
issue on behalf of the Patriots he
abandoned the appeals there was
potential for litigation that wasn't
pursued his thought was and he said this
after Tom Brady got suspended for games
he thought by standing down he was
securing more lenient treatment for Tom
Brady so either he misread the room four
years ago or the room was misrepresented
to him but to the extent that he
remembers that and surely he does
because the rest of us do he's going to
be leery about doing any wink nod deals
with the NFL this time around that's not
to say it can't happen but that's gonna
be a factor in all of this as well and
if something does happen quickly if it
does go away in the next few weeks he's
gonna be making a leap of faith that
whatever someone at 3:45 Park Avenue has
told him is gonna be the punishment that
maybe that won't be the punishment and
maybe there'll be something more
stringent so nobody knows what the
Commissioner is going to do I've also
suggested that maybe Kraft will impose
on himself a punishment that will be
sufficiently stringent that anyone would
say well yeah that's not that's not too
lenient he is selecting his own
suspension he's selecting his own fine
taking this off the commissioner's plate
because really you know i mean say what
you will about the commissioner he
didn't ask for this one and and he's in
a tough spot now where he's got a
balance those who would say you're being
too lenient versus those who who would
say that you're going too far so if
there is a way that Kraft could fashion
his own punishment that would actually
help the commissioner out of a very
delicate spot so my other question is
how much do the other owners play a part
in a case like this where they have to
figure out you know even if he's
completely you know free of all charges
and walks free and and everything is
thrown out in court you still have the
conduct policy and they can basically
make the argument well it looks bad for
the NFL that he even was named in this
to begin with so my question to you is
the owners so the regular the rest of
the owners are they sitting there
saying well this is the guy who keeps
beating us in Super Bowls and keeps
owning the league or do they say hey
this is one of our guys and this could
happen to you know if you're sitting
there and you're an owner event NFL team
you could be in this position someday
you want your fellow owners to back you
up until Roger Goodell don't don't throw
the book at him take it easy on him it's
a misdemeanor how does that play into
the whole dynamic here well you know
that's a tough balance as well because
what happened with deflate gate there
were multiple reports that there were
owners pushing for a more stringent
punishment of the Patriots because there
was still lingering resentment that they
didn't do enough to the Patriots in
Spygate in 2007 and there's going to be
resentment he has kicked everyone's ass
for the last 18 years he has six Super
Bowl trophies there are owners out there
that don't like it now they're not gonna
stand up and say boy you know we're glad
to see he's getting what's you know he's
getting something negative happening to
his franchise you know we we can't beat
him on the field so we'll revel in
anything that happens that we can that
we can feel better about ourselves about
but you know I think at the end of the
day they need to realize these standards
can apply to them as well and and and so
there's a balance there but I suspect
there'll be some owners who who will be
behind the scenes trying to stick a
knife in Bob crafts back because that's
the way you know sometimes billionaires
operate in a highly competitive
environment
okay last big question for you Mike and
I think I've handled myself very well in
this and I also credit to us because
this news came out all after we did the
show together on Friday and that was
probably the save of your entire career
but my last question to you is what are
the chances that Bob Kraft just says you
know what it was time already I'm gonna
let my son take over the team and walk
away so there's not even a punishment
like the there can't be a punishment
because he's not the owner of the New
England Patriots anymore because I think
if you probably sat down before this
even happened Bob Kraft would have said
you know the plan is my son is gonna
take over the team in the next three to
five years regardless of what happens
yeah I mean that's a possibility we
don't know what he wants out of all this
and for all we know now he intends to
fight it tooth and nail and
prove that he didn't do it that he is
innocent but you look at what happened
with Jerry Richardson back in late 2017
I had somebody asked me yesterday well
could could the NFL take away the
Patriots force him to sell the way that
they forced G rich and so they didn't
force Jerry Richardson to sell he chose
to do it on his own and there's no
reason to think the NFL would have even
had the power to force him to sell
that's what Richardson chose to do once
it came to light that there had been
some workplace issues that resulted in
settlements that had confidentiality
clauses some of the facts came out it
was embarrassing to Jerry Richardson so
he just said you know what I'm gonna
sell anyway at some point let's just do
it now
so it's there's a similarity there
there's a similar threat the idea that
if Robert Kraft is thinking you know
what at some point I was going to hand
the reins to Jonathan I may as well just
do it now and if that becomes part of
the punishment that he imposes on
himself to take because again that's
what Richardson did for Roger Goodell
Richardson didn't put Roger Goodell in a
tough spot and this would be a way to
not put Roger Goodell in a tough spot
as it relates to coming up with some
sort of a discipline to be imposed
personally on Robert Kraft and that
wouldn't shock me if that's the outcome
again for now though the indication is
they're gonna fight this thing and we'll
see if that fight plays out the court
date the first court date it doesn't
have to be there for this his lawyer
will be there on April 24 that just
shows you how slow this process is big
cat I mean here we are it's February 26
it's gonna be two months before there's
even that first moment where you walk
into court and get scheduling and do the
My Cousin Vinny guilty or not guilty
routine and and and off it goes and who
knows how long it takes in the court
system before it finally gets to a
conclusion yeah and reading all the you
know everything I've read since the
report came out on Friday is that Robert
Kraft will never have to probably appear
in court so that saves him that
embarrassment of a mug shot and a perp
walk and all that stuff so it's going to
be one of those stories that will always
linger but I think that the big initial
shock has kind of waned off and we won't
have that moment where you know it will
be it will be like you said a court
filing that will then somehow get to the
press and people will read about it but
it won't be that big splash that you'll
see where you see Robert Kraft walking
into court or you see some big moment in
kort it's not none of that's gonna
happen it's gonna all take place behind
closed doors and we're gonna hear about
it but it's gonna be two months down the
line unless he chooses to fight this
thing and at some point there will be a
trial it may be a year from now it may
be two years from now who knows but if
he decides I am gonna push this to the
limit I can prove my innocence or there
there's you know there were some other
argument that can be made it's a high
standard in in a criminal justice
proceeding to prove that guilt beyond a
reasonable doubt if he chooses to do
that and he has every right to do it
then this could take some time and then
at some point he would have to go to
court and and presumably would wait and
he doesn't have to testify that's one of
the things we all learned from watching
TV and very rarely does a criminal
defendant get on the stand and testify
because the chances are you gonna get
ripped to shreds by the prosecutor on
cross-examination but at some point if
he does decide he wants full exoneration
and there isn't a deal to be struck then
there will be a court proceeding but I
don't think it gets to that but if it
does get to that I think it's way down
the line
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports